perfect queen of everything Beyonce was
finally proven mortal this past weekend
when her earring ripped out during a
performance causing her to emit what
appears to be human blood she's fine I
think she's used to it Beyonce blood is
what the Illuminati used to begin their
Christmas parties she finished the
concert like a pro but some of the more
fervent members of the beyhive are
showing their solidarity by making
themselves what is our culture with the
hashtag cut for Beyonce this is
ridiculous especially considering not a
single person show their solidarity last
year with the hashtag whip your dick out
for Lenny Kravitz nobody it was to get
away what are people doing in solidarity
with other musicians Jonah in solidarity
fans of sublime are sucking oh Jesus
Christ you know they had some good songs
Jonah no they didn't all right points in
solidarity with Keith Richards fans are
hiding heroin in their walkers yes boys